[Music]
we're doing a very small coveted
conscious shoe distribution event
for the kids in need at saint jude's
ranch for children our programming is
critically important right now
particularly with
having been through the pandemic and so
many kids staying home in social
distancing not being in school
as we're gearing up to get back into the
schools it's really important these kids
have new shoes a lot of them
shoes have probably been forgone to rent
groceries we want to get them in brand
new shoes as they head back to school
this is a new event for us because
normally we do work within the school
district to serve title 1 tier 1 schools
so having the opportunity to work with
an agency as great as st
jude's and reach out to these kids who
are living in residential foster care
programs it's a great opportunity for us
to have big impact right now
a new pair of shoes is an incredible
gift for all of our kids it's also a
sign of hope right it helps our kids
feel good about
themselves and you know our kids are so
excited to be going back to school
hopefully really soon
and you know we hadn't planned back to
school and now we have this amazing
opportunity so new shoes you know even
during covid our kids feet have still
been growing